la population mondiale ne cesse
d'augmenter depuis des siècles on
pourrait croire que ces tendances va se
poursuivre indéfiniment en fait la
réalité est tout autre
[Musique]
ça y est on y est 8 milliards d'humains
sur terre
l'Organisation des Nations Unies
confirme
mine de rien c'est trois fois plus qu'en
1950 trois fois plus d'humains à puiser
dans les mêmes ressources de la bonne
vieille terre mais cela pourrait changer
la croissance de la population mondiale
n'est pas infinie
au contraire un déclin est en vue
[Musique]
pour la première fois le nu prévoit que
le pic sera atteint autour de 2080
nous serions alors
10,4 milliards d'humains un nombre qui
selon les estimations de l'ONU se
maintiendrait quelques années avant de
décliner
d'autres experts en démographie croient
au contraire que ce pic sera atteint
plutôt vers 2050
au point où la population mondiale en
2005 serait plus petite qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le déclin annoncé de la population
mondiale et contre-intuitif puisque de
façon générale on vit plus vieux mais on
fait aussi moins d'enfants
les deux tiers des gens vivent dans un
pays où le taux de fécondité étant de ça
de 2,1 enfant par femme
si ce taux qui assure le renouvellement
d'une population
par conséquent le nombre de morts
annuels va bientôt dépasser le nombre de
naissances dans le monde on constate
déjà dans certains pays comme en Russie
mais aussi en Chine où la population a
commencé à décliner en 2022
celle de l'Afrique au contraire va
augmenter
celle du Canada aussi principalement
chez nous en raison de l'immigration
partant du principe que plus il y a du
même plus la pression est grande sur les
ressources naturelles un décline de
population mondiale pourrait-il donner
un répit à la terre
[Musique]
le problème c'est que la pression sur
les ressources ne dépend pas que du
nombre d'humains et dépend aussi de leur
niveau de consommation
[Musique]
on note aussi dans les pays nanti que le
nombre de foyers augmente plus vite que
la population pourquoi à cause d'un trou
des divorces et du fait que de plus en
plus de gens vivent seuls comme le foyer
constitue une sorte d'unité sur laquelle
se fonde la consommation plus il y a de
foyer plus il y a de consommation
la pression sur les ressources dont
l'énergie est liée entre autres à la
distance de plus en plus grande que les
produits doivent désormais parcourir
avant de se rendre au consommateur
aujourd'hui la majorité de la population
mondiale habitent dans des villes loin
des centres de production une production
maintenant délocalisée et mondialisée ce
qui est à moins le cas dans les années
s’ajoute à notre consommation qui grimpe
le fait que le cycle de vie des produits
consommés s'écoute le gaspillage des
ressources s'ensuit
en bout de piste on voit bien que la
diminution de la population mondiale ne
se traduit pas forcément par une
embellie pour la planète
cela dépendra davantage d'un changement
dans nos modes de consommation et d'une
prise de conscience humaine des
ressources limitées de la terre